welcome all of you I recently came back
from a trip to Hanoi and I picked up
this I had a wonderful little propaganda
poster shop how many of you have been to
Vietnam ok good this is I don't speak
Vietnamese with as a convenient
translation here that says the national
empires and reaction shouldn't unwise
touch this country a little bit awkward
there but clearly a symbol of resistance
to foreign forces but what I found
particularly tricking about this poster
is the date 1978 so this is after the
war against the United States but it's
still a very militaristic symbol of
resistance against whom what was
happening in Vietnam in 1978 we'll get
to that in a moment my assignment was to
talk about the Vietnam War in Asian
history in the context of Asian history
but as I dealt more deeply into the
subject it occurred to me that what
might be useful for this class is a
shift of emphasis away from examining
the war in Vietnam as part of American
history which is the way most Americans
understand it still today and to put the
war which in Vietnam is called the
American War into the context of
Southeast Asian and specifically
Vietnamese history and if we look at it
from that perspective we see the war
which looms extraordinarily large in our
understanding of his history of history
of the United States and the world is
actually a rather small segment of a
much longer history first of all of
conflict in Vietnam and on the
indo-chinese Peninsula and even more
broadly in the long history of Vietnam
itself so I want to look at that
or in those two context and i will get
toward the end to the american war or to
the Vietnam American War which is a term
I would like to use for it today but I
want to backup and get a rather long
term perspective on the overall history
of this region and of this country
called Vietnam as the Vietnamese
government kept reminding Americans for
many years as a process of normalization
dragged on in the 1990s Vietnam is a
country not a war and that is still
something I think worth keeping in mind
today more than 30 years after the war
between the United States and anti-us
anti South Vietnamese forces has ended I
also wanted to touch on toward the end
of the talk about how the war or wars
are remembered both in the United States
in Vietnam which of course is now
unified under the Hanoi government and
to a limited extent which is because it
is not something I am deeply familiar
with the Vietnamese diaspora Vietnamese
outside of Vietnam particularly in the
United States we are re-examining those
of us in the field of history
particularly those who focus on
Vietnamese history specifically which I
did not my interest it came to Vietnam
rather indirectly through my work on
Korea which is reflected in the article
that my that you have seen in your
reading there has been a reexamination
of the kind of accepted narratives of
this history recently in the scholarship
on the history of Vietnam that there is
a there are multiple ways in which this
history can be remembered in certain
things which we for various size of the
conflict took for granted are now being
re-examined in new ways and in
particular this narrative of nationalism
and
the Vietnamese nation and of this
history being a history of conflict
between a sort of timeless Vietnamese
essence and foreign threats we still
find this today in Hanoi since it is
obviously it was a certain sense the
underpinning of the legitimacy of the
regime but also in still much of the
common understanding and even the
scholarship on the Vietnam War that
Vietnam is a history of continuous
resistance against foreign invasion
against the Chinese against the French
against the Americans that that is not
to say that these events are not part of
history there's not to say that there
wasn't resistance and there wasn't
conflict and that there is not a strong
sense of national unity and nationalism
in Vietnam but certainly there certainly
is but simply that we are now at a point
where we are some removed from the war
and the kinds of issues that the war
brought to the forefront both in Vietnam
and the United States and we are able to
look at some of the more complicated
stories of history with in Vietnam the
history of the relations of Vietnam with
its neighbors and with the European
powers and with the United States but I
don't want to get too much into this
again this is not my particular field
I'm not a historian of Vietnam it is
something that I've come to through the
nation with this particular period that
you are studying in this course and I
become as it were somewhat of an amateur
a dabbler in the history of Vietnam but
also in a comparative perspective having
been trained in the history of East Asia
both China and Korea I find a great deal
of comparative of richness in looking at
the history of Vietnam from that
perspective when I was in Hanoi a few
weeks ago I
attach myself to a Princeton group which
attended a lecture in value of the
confucian temple the temple of
literature by a very prominent
Vietnamese historian the lecture was
called 3000 years of Vietnamese history
in one hour I won't quite give you that
but I will go over quite a bit of very
quickly some of earlier Vietnamese
history and then get into the 20th
century in particular period of the wars
in Indochina so what I like to talk
about today is not the vietnam war in
american history which is largely what
we are studying here but rather the
opposite perspective the american war in
vietnamese history first of all do we
know who knows who this person is in the
picture no
that is a new in van to the president of
the republic of vietnam in hawaii in a
visit with johnson in 1968 looking at a
map of the asia-pacific and when
presumes staring at his own country here
in Southeast Asia to begin with we
should look at the american war in the
context of three conflicts on the
indo-chinese peninsula that erupted
shortly after the end of World War two
in 1946 and continued until nineteen
eighty Indochina as we'll talk about in
a moment as the term of the French used
for their colonial possession in
Southeast Asia which includes the
countries of Vietnam Laos and Cambodia
and the initial War was between French
forces who attempted to reassert French
control in this region and nationalist
or antique French forces led by the Viet
Minh of the Vietnamese League for
independence this went on until April
May 1954 when the Geneva Conference on
Indochina reached a conclusion on piece
on the end of Chinese Peninsula and the
removal of French authority from its
former colony this led to a period of
division and instability within the
Vietnamese region and escalating
American military presence until the
first contingent of American combat
forces came to Vietnam in late 64 1965
and that is conventionally there are
different ways of dating this when the
American phase or the American War began
which could also be called the second
Indochina war which continued from then
until the fall of Saigon
cuesta saigon by National Liberal
Liberation Front and North Vietnamese
forces in april of nineteen seventy five
the Americans as a combat force were as
you probably know gone by 1973 but the
war is thought usually to have ended
with the fall of Saigon in april
nineteen seventy five then and this is
where our poster comes in there was not
a prolonged peace but a new period of
tension on the indo-chinese peninsula
between the new newly installed
communist regime in pompeii and cambodia
led by the cambodian Communist Party but
popularly referred to then n now as the
Khmer Rouge the red Khmer to the terms
of the French gave to them the Chimaera
are the dominant ethnic group of
Cambodia and the the unified socialist
republic of vietnam which became
increasingly aligned with the Soviet
Union committed the Khmer Rouge the
Cambodian government was backed by China
there was a series of border clashes
between the Vietnamese and Cambodians
over the course of the late 1970s and
then finally a Vietnamese invasion of
Cambodia in late nineteen seventy eight
which was followed by a border war
between China and Vietnam in 79 80 much
this was a much smaller conflict both
the contained geographically and in
terms of the destruction in the first to
China awards but it is still
conventionally referred to as the third
Indochina war one might say that in fact
the wars in Vietnam didn't really end
until much later there was a ten-year
occupation of Vietnam in Cambodia from
nineteen seventy nine to nineteen eighty
nine and Vietnam at that time was under
a very harsh sanctions regime led by the
United States the government that was
supported by Vietnam in Cambodia was
boycotted by the United Nations which
supported a
tripartite government in exile which
included non-communist forces Royalists
under of the prince and then king
norodom siano and the khmer rouge backed
by china with the end of the vietnamese
occupation 1989 the end of the Cold War
in general the Cambodian government then
held elections in 1992 and the sanctions
were eventually lifted in nineteen
ninety three to nineteen ninety-five by
the United States and the US and Vietnam
normalized relations so we could say
that from a certain perspective the
active phase of conflict between the
United States and North Vietnam with the
National Liberation Front in the South
was a relatively small but particularly
destructive and significant phase of a
more or less unending conflict that
began in in 1946 and ended in 1995 that
is 50 years okay where are we now let us
go back then to put these conflicts in
turn in a much large historical context
and that is the overall place of Vietnam
in East and Southeast Asian history the
most obvious and the most in certain
ways powerful external force in the
history of Vietnam has been China coming
from the perspective of Korean history i
find interesting comparisons and
contrasts between careers relationship
with China and viet nam's both Korea and
Vietnam were relatively small kingdoms
on the periphery of China Korea to the
to the Northeast Vietnam to the
southwest both interestingly enough were
conquered by the same Han Chinese
general around the time of Christ and
both were pacified the the Korean area
was given the name on dome were pacified
East
by the Chinese there is still until the
mid 20th century a city on the sino
Korean border called that on dong the
pacified East it's now called dandome or
the red east and in the south the area
which we call Vietnam where the northern
part of Vietnam was called the pacified
south on none or annum which is still a
name used for Vietnam and as we'll see
part of the French colonial possession
of Indochina this is a map of the Tang
Dynasty in China and you can see that in
the Kent I don't have a pointer here do
we have anything that can use to point
that out long stick something I should
have brought my own but we can see this
region here which is now part of Vietnam
incorporated into the tang dynasty into
Chinese rule so there has there are a
number of competing in some ways
complementary ways of looking at this
relationship between Vietnam and China
on the one hand there's been a great
deal of cultural exchange or what many
certainly from the Chinese perspective
would call cultural borrowing from from
China the people of what we now call
Vietnam at least the literate elite
adopted Confucian principles of
governance family ritual philosophy much
of Chinese high culture including the
arts calligraphy the use of the written
language Hospital Chinese although over
time the viennese also developed a
modified use of Chinese characters for
parts of the language which could not be
expressed in a strictly classical
Chinese which was the language of the
literati a similar process went on in
Korea and Japan to which also adopted
chinese culture heavily and particularly
at this time the tongue
eighth ninth centuries sorry 7th to 8th
centuries but on the other hand china in
a certain sense because of its very
utility as a model of government
governance a political structure became
the focus of the creation of a sense of
nation asst as it were of political
independence with in Vietnam itself and
the a certain kind of Vietnamese story
is that the Vietnam Vietnamese resisted
China were resisted Chinese domination
for a thousand years of the Han Dynasty
to the Tang Dynasty if you look I think
into that story it's much more
complicated than that for one thing who
the Vietnamese are who the Chinese are
is not always entirely clear at this
time but there I think it's fair to say
overall there is a deeply ambivalent
history between China and Vietnam that
goes very far back and one of the
profound misconceptions of the American
war effort in Vietnam was that the
Chinese and the Vietnamese were natural
historical allies a part of global
communism but particularly the Asiatic
the Asian variation of global communism
and they were largely indistinguishable
in fact there were tensions from the
very beginning between the Vietnamese
and communist movements in the 20th
century and it should not have come as a
complete surprise that conflict would
come out in the open between China and
Vietnam after unification 1975 and as
we've seen even a short war between
China Vietnam at the end of the 1970s I
don't know if any of them caught the
article in yesterday's New York Times
about the controversy in between China
and Vietnam or actually with in Vietnam
about Chinese investments in Vietnamese
mining to anybody see that the very
interesting story because the V
his communist party is very bullish on
inviting Chinese investment into Vietnam
but some NGOs and individuals are quite
opposed to it for environmental reasons
and also for out of concern about
Chinese economic hegemony in Vietnam and
the kind of as it were symbolic leader
of this resistance or one figure who has
come out very strongly and very publicly
against the Chinese economic incursion
into Vietnamese mining interests is one
is job the great general of the Vietnam
War and one of the current of communist
party leaders was quoted as saying well
he was asked what do you think of Japs
opposition to Chinese investment he said
well we have great due respect for
generals yet but he's almost a hundred
years old and he he kind of lives in the
past so there is from very early in this
history to the present day a deeply
ambivalent relationship between China
and Vietnam and that that figures in in
significant ways in various periods in
this history including the war which you
study in this course there is on the one
hand a history of cultural borrowing
history of cultural exchange as i
mentioned Confucianism statecraft
written language Buddhism which of
course originates from India but enters
into Vietnam largely through a Chinese
transmutation in the form of Mahayana
Buddhism and classical Chinese text
there are various stories of resistance
against China the most famous press
being with Hong sisters in the from 39
to 40 to ad who fought unsuccessfully in
the end against the reassertion of
domination by the Han Dynasty in China
and were executed for their for their
efforts
the han han dynasty records is where we
first obtain much of our written
understanding through chinese of course
of this early history over now co viet
nam the chinese called the people of the
southern frontier the US which is still
a term used for minority group within
china and those in the in the far south
in the red river delta area around what
is now called hanoi and ended environs
were called the southern you at nanuet
or nam viet in vietnamese and this is a
term that over time was adopted by the
indigenous people of this region
themselves the nam viet the southern us
southern viet people but gradually this
change to the the people of the south of
us or vietnam and that of course is the
contemporary term for this region also
die via the great viet ppl is another
term that oh in more recent history has
been used with that so this is the
origin of that a Chinese
conceptualization of a sort of semi
civilized people on its Frontier which
became indigenous as a term for the
local people themselves there is another
way of looking at this history as well
which has come under criticism recently
but also has some very interesting
implications for what we think about
recent history of this region and that
is the kind of southern expansion of
these your viet ppl the southern
expansion of Vietnamese culture which
which has its origins in the Red River
Delta in the north but gradually moves
south it's blocked to the west because
of the mountain ranges which now provide
the boundary between Vietnam proper and
Laos
and Cambodia at least down to the Mekong
Delta and there were various groups of
different cultures languages religions
throughout this history and the final
formation of the contemporary boundaries
of Vietnam did not occur until the early
19th century of the Gotham emperor in
1802 if you're planning to visit her
knowing next year it is there is a gala
celebration of the 1,000th anniversary
they say of the founding of the city
tongue long as it was called at that
time the ascending dragon and this is a
rather I would say northern centric
history which sees a certain kind of
inevitability in the extension of
Vietnamese culture south until it
fulfills its present boundaries but
there is much more going on even into
the 20th century then simply a kind of
natural extension of Vietnamese culture
and indeed part of the background of the
war that emerged between cambodia and
vietnam in 1978-79 was precisely the
contestation of who belongs or what
country dominates the mekong river delta
and this culturally somewhat complicated
in vague region between Cambodia and
Vietnam this is not to say that the
division of Vietnam has occurred in 1954
was somehow a natural division the sense
of Vietnam having a unified history and
identity was certainly quite widespread
and even a dominant by the by the early
20th century but simply that by a in a
way buying into this northern centric
narrative we tend to occlude or tend to
suppress other ways of understanding
this
in some ways very complicated history
and one of the one of the suppressed
histories as I'll get to where the end
of this talk is the history of South
Vietnam itself which has been more or
less subsumed even erased by the post
unification narrative of the extension
of national history as Hanoi sees it
briefly in the third sort of area so
first of all there is the relationship
in Vietnam honest great northern
neighbor China second there is the
extension southward or the interaction
of the core as it were of Vietnamese
culture of the north with the people of
the south and then there is a third
direction more recently in Vietnamese
history that is it encounters with the
West which began at least in the 1500s
with traders from Portugal Russia
elsewhere and in the 17th century the
French initially through missionary work
become become to be involved in
Vietnamese affairs as and zeros the road
of French Jesuit priest adopted the
Roman alphabet Vietnamese language a he
I think did not do it single-handedly
but with the cooperation of Vietnamese
scholars and that has become the written
language as we see in a poster today of
Vietnam and by the late eighteenth and
early nineteenth century the French
military interest for variety of reasons
not least of which was its competition
with Britain which was coming to
dominate India decided to move much more
aggressively into the region between
India and China which the French called
and ocean or Indochina which was a term
that became commonly adopted in the west
until the middle of the 20th century or
so French Indochina was a kind of
fiction that existed from the late
eighteen late 19th century until
the Geneva Accords of 1954 which took a
number of rather distinct cultural areas
and lump them together into a single
French dominated region it wasn't a
single colony however but it was
administered in five regions there were
three what we call the three countries
of Vietnam Cambodia and Laos were
divided into five parts southern Vietnam
which the French called Koshien Xin
cosentino coach in China which was
administered directly through Saigon as
a colony at aankhen and anam there is
that term again note which were northern
and central Vietnam respectively and
Cambodia and Laos which were ruled
indirectly as protectorates and the
capital of all of French Indochina was
Hanoi there was a as a reaction to this
there were on the one hand economic and
social changes that came about through
the modernization which was a very it
must be said limited and uneven
modernization but nevertheless there
were sometimes very dramatic changes
within Indochina under French rule both
negative and positive but also an
emergence by the late 19th early 20th
century of a modern sense and a modern
kind of infrastructure intellectually
speaking and later politically of
Vietnamese nationalism the picture on
the top is from 2007 movie the rebel
starring johnny nguyen i believe that i
believe the fellow is kicking french but
in 1922 I think this you can see the
sort of continued power of this
narrative of resistance and nationalism
with in Vietnam and on the bottom two
leading intellectuals and political
figures of the emerging national spoon
which I'll get to in a moment so as in
colonialism elsewhere
both in French colonial possessions and
British Dutch in Southeast Asia and so
forth there was a two-sided aspect to
colonial rule on the one hand changes
exploitations but also modernization
processes under colonial rule and also
the emergence of various kinds of
resistance against it which coalesced
over time in the case of Vietnam into
what became a very it must be said
powerful movement for independence and a
desire to create a modern nation by the
early 20th century it took many forms of
which L is to hear farm boy child the
person who left who was a classically
trained scholar and originally what he
called a go east movement which
advocated that young Vietnamese learn
from Japan and other East Asian
countries and ally with them and
resisting the West that in the end did
not lead very far toward independence
and the person on the on the right who
had many pseudonyms but who is known to
us today as Ho Chi Minh was also an
early national figure but gravitated
toward socialism which was coming into
vogue in his time in the early 20th
century he was one of the founders of
the French Communist Party in 1920
during his period of Exile in Paris and
eventually helped to found the
indochinese communist party in the
Vietnamese Communist Party we will get
back to Uncle Ho as he is called in
Vietnam again of course in 1940 after
Germany occupied France into china
became under the control of the
collaborationist government based in
Vichy and the Vichy ruler is allowed the
japanese which we see in the top photo
coming across the Red River in their
bicycles into Vietnam
in the same year ho chi minh forms the
vietnamese league for independence sorry
which is a was a coalition of various
patriotic groups of which the most
significant was but certainly not the
only one was the Communist Party and its
abbreviation or was the Viet Ming which
is what it became well known for
throughout the periods of the French and
the American wars so the end of the
second world war Japan took over Vietnam
and Indochina directly and on all this
15th 1945 japan surrendered to the
allies around the same time ho chi minh
came back into vietnam from china and
declared the democratic republic of
vietnam on September second 1945 the dr
v which is a and a group of ho ho chi
minh aligned resistance fighters is
shown there in the bottom photo this
period of independence did not last very
long for reasons which your readings in
the vietnam war book show i think in
some considerable detail the americans
supported the return of the fridge to
Indochina the initial resistance to
continue french colonization which
roosevelt advocated was replacement a
truman by a calculation that the more
important concern in the region was the
spread of communism and therefore
allowing the french to have a role in
post-colonial vietnam was preferable to
allowing the domination of an
independent vietnam by ho chi minh and
his communist essentially and for
reasons of prestige economic benefits
and others the french decided to return
to Indochina and
indochina into a new french union this
sparked a quite powerful resistance led
by the Viet Minh against the research
and French rule the United States after
initial ambivalence decided to support
the French by the end of the french
effort in Vietnam the u.s. was
financially supporting the French
military effort to close to eighty
percent so although the United States
was not directly involved they were very
much present in terms of assistance to
the French effort which finally
collapsed with the Vietnam victory at
gym bein pool a small base near the
Laotian border in april nineteen fifty
four at exactly the time that there was
the conference going on in geneva to
conclude a peace in Indochina now this
leads to their a period of divided
vietnam from 1954 to the fall of saigon
in april of nineteen seventy five the
decision at geneva was a temporary
division leading ultimately to elections
within two years or so by the summer of
nineteen fifty-six was its goal but
there was a a great deal of anxiety on
the American side about this there was
also a sense of betrayal on the viet
minh site as well ho chi minh and his
allies felt that the Chinese and Soviets
should have supported his Democratic
Republic of Vietnam as legitimate
government of all of Vietnam but for
their own reasons the Chinese in the
Soviets who were backing what she meant
compromised with the Americans and
essentially Vietnam got the Korea
solution just as Korea had been divided
at the 38th parallel in 1945 and was
divided by a demilitarized zone at the
end of the Korean War in July 1953 so it
was thought the most expedient solution
would be a division of Vietnam at what
as a turn
the 17th parallel which roughly divided
the country in half with Hanoi the
capital of the DRV and in the north and
Saigon the capital of a new state of
Vietnam in the south but the attempt to
create a stable South Vietnamese state
was from the beginning troubled by
insurgency and instability there was a
regrouping of the two sides a very
significant movement of people from the
north to the south particularly
Catholics but also others as well who
were not happy with which he means drv
and the initial head of state of the
state of vietnam was the heir to the
last dynasty ball dive who was replaced
and we won't get into the complicated
history here by a series of civilian and
military presidents and at the top as
well as at the bottom that is to say at
the level of the political structure as
well as the question of social stability
South Vietnam was throughout its history
a society which never seemed to quite
cole s long enough to create a stable
long-lasting regime allied with the west
and with the United States this then
ultimately led to the second under China
war the American War which as I
mentioned began begins in 1964-65 and
continues until the American withdrawal
in 1973 and the false i got in 1975 but
as i want to point out and what my
article tries to show as well it wasn't
merely an american war it was a war that
in certain sense was very much
internationalized it was first and
foremost a war between vietnamese a war
with in vietnam but it was also a war
that expressed the cold war conflict
globally on the southern side there were
us-allied combatants the army of the
republic of vietnam or Arvin the south
vietnamese forces
South Korea which sent the second
largest foreign contingent which is
often forgotten there were three hundred
twenty-five thousand South Korean
soldiers that went to Vietnam over the
course of this war 55,000 at its peak in
1967 which was about ten percent of the
American force of half a million but
seven or eight times more than the next
largest group the Thai courses followed
by Australians and New Zealand's there
were also other countries the
Philippines for example which sent
non-combatants to a the American Airport
in Vietnam on the northern side there
was no direct military involvement of
combat forces allied to North Vietnam
but there was considerable Soviet and
Chinese of military assistance in terms
of advice and material including very
significant weaponry tanks airplanes and
so forth as well as North Korea East
German and other East Bloc supplies and
support and finally one very important
international aspect of the war was
world opinion it was the first war to be
broadcast through television at a time
when television became widespread in the
developed West and it was a war in which
global opinion fought fiercely about and
had a very important role to play in it
not only American opinion of course
which was deeply divided over the war
but also the opinions of American allies
and opponents in Europe in Asia and
elsewhere so the Vietnam War was not
just an American war not just an
American Vietnamese War but also a kind
of global conflict in which the
involvement and the observation of
people around the world was implicated
in the way the war in which the way in
which the war was conducted and
included as i said i would skip very
quickly through the war we have lots of
time to go to the details of the war
itself but i want to get to the subject
of how the war ended and how it is
remembered and also how it is forgotten
as i will talk about in a moment the
american war ended in 1975 with the
unification of vietnam something that
the northern forces and Ho Chi Minh in
particular had devoted great passion and
energy to Ho Chi Minh himself died in
1969 and not live to see the war
concluded but the country was devastated
by 30 years of conflict was economically
isolated I was beset by internal and
external tensions which eventually led
to the third into China war breaking out
at the end of the 1970s and continued
American policy of economically and
politically isolating I'm a socialist
republic of vietnam phrase used at that
time rather unkindly was a bleeding
vietnam white as a kind of way in which
i'll be that there were perhaps
legitimate reasons to criticize and
oppose the communist government of
Vietnam was also i think cannot be
denied a way for the United States to to
win the peace and to get as it were
revenge on the people who defeated it
it's often been said if you compare
Germany and Japan and their post war
situations in the relationship of the
United States to Vietnam that perhaps
the best thing you can do for your
country is to fight a war with the
United States and lose but the worst
thing you can do is to fight a war with
the United States and win and this is a
lesson that the Vietnamese learn to
their detriment in the end with the
breakup of the Cold War and ultimately
the collapse of the Soviet Union the
Vietnamese
regime had little choice but to move in
the direction of economic reform domo or
restructuring which is basically a
translation of Gorbachev's perestroika
that emerged just before this was a way
in which the communist party could
retain political control but also open
up the country economically enough to
bring modernization to what had become a
very backward and poorer society after
the war and that restriction continues
to the present with that in the end of
the Cold War the way was paved for
eventual us Vietnamese normalization
which preceded in fits and starts but
finally succeeded in 1995 under
President Clinton memorializing the
Vietnam American War let me call it that
today on the one hand you see in the
left hand picture we of course have the
Vietnam War Memorial design of the early
1980s on the mall in Washington and on
the right a monument to the Vietnamese
dead the fatherland will remember your
sacrifice says in the obelisk perhaps
58,000 Americans died the number of
Vietnamese is contentious and will
probably never be known for sure but the
general figure given is about three
million of the course of the American
War civilian and military together there
is a difference between memorializing of
course to set up a monument to this
conflict in remembering and the
remembering of the war is a complicated
affair with many sides to it there is
the official Vietnamese remembering of
what the war was about a war of heroic
resistance against the Americans we see
the poster on the left of the 30th
anniversary of the Christmas bombing of
Hanoi and the people the fist with the
Vietnamese flag on the cuff smashing an
American b-52
on the right the way in which the war
was remembered most vividly for a long
time after its end was the issue of POWs
and em IAS which is a complicated and
very interesting story of a kind of
reinterpretation of the american war
with the Americans as victims and one of
the major stumbling blocks to
normalization and 1997 it was decreed
that the this Black Flag the p.o wmia
flag had to be hoisted at certain
occasions in the United States and we
still see it in many places around this
country and one of the most forgotten
voices is the voice of the people of the
earth while republic of vietnam in the
south which is represented by that flag
on the lower right hand many of the of
the people involved in the Saigon
government and the system were broadly
fled the country after reunification in
1975 to form the core of various
diaspora communities and friends in
Australia and in the United States and
to this day the way in which Vietnam is
represented which flag to use is a bone
of great contention sometimes a violent
one among the Vietnamese diaspora
community but there is also a forgetting
the war here's a street scene from
Saigon and if you are from sorry from
Hanoi rather typical one if you walk the
streets of hanoi you have to learn the
skill of walking through incredibly
heavy motorcycle traffic without losing
life or limb most of the people the
majority of the people alive in Vietnam
today were born after 1975 and therefore
have no memory of the war and I was
particularly struck this time I visited
Hanoi just a few weeks ago how much even
within the last 10 years or so the
memory of the war has faded I had a
great deal of difficulty finding
souvenirs even in Hanoi that had any
reference to the war
all the war is something in the distant
past that is of little relevance to
people's lives today the Vietnamese
would rather move on with their economic
development with their society and with
their relationship with their neighbors
and with the United States you can see
the word do I in the upper left hand
corner and very small letters in the
poster and that has been the dominant
narrative of Vietnam over the last 20
years of restructuring of moving on and
forgetting rather than remember the
history that still remains so painfully
with us here in this country and is
associated with the word Vietnam itself
ok I'll stop here thank you what should
we do should we break for a moment or
should I I I would be happy to open up
for discussion for a while ok can I turn
this off